les manifestations et surtout les
arrestations qui ont émaillé ces
protestations ont suscité l'indignation
de nombreux responsables occidentaux
joe biden a dénoncé dimanche des
méthodes brutales contre les
manifestants et journalistes et jean
yves le drian y voient une atteinte à
l'état de droit
son homologue allemand s'est également
exprimé sur le sujet un peu plus tôt
dans la journée le gouvernement allemand
a clairement fait savoir après
l'arrestation de monsieur navalni que
nous ne comprenons pas cette démarche et
a exigé la libération immédiate de
monsieur navalni cela vaut également
pour les manifestations du week-end car
les manifestants qui ont été arrêtés par
les forces de sécurité et selon la
constitution russe
tout le monde a le droit d'exprimer ses
opinions et de manifester en russie les
principes de l'état de droit doivent
également s'y appliquer la russie s'est
toujours engagé dans cette voie et c'est
pourquoi nous attendons de ceux qui ont
protesté pacifiquement là bas qu'il n'y
ait aucune autre arrestation ni raison
de les arrêter ils doivent être libérés
immédiatement
en marge de ces réactions le
porte-parole du kremlin a lui dénoncé
l'ingérence de l'ambassade des états
unis à moscou estimant qu'elle avait
publié sur son site internet des
informations susceptibles d'encourager
les protestataires
interrogé sur les manifestations de ce
samedi le président russe a lui aussi
réagi en faisant un parallèle avec les
récents événements du capitole un ciel
ou d'éliminer toute personne a le droit
d'exprimer son point de vue dans le
cadre prévu par la loi
tout ce qui dépasse ce cadre n'est pas
seulement contre-productif mais
dangereux jetons à washington des
manifestants ont pris d'assaut le
parlement
que fait-on de ces gens un responsable
du fbi haye a déclaré nous avons le bras
long nous allons trouver arrêter et
mettre tout le monde en prison en liège
toi mais je touche à gauche les
politiques chinoises noah et kaman et
leur infliger de 15 à 25 ans de prison
comme pour le terrorisme local ces gens
eux aussi sont sortis pour faire
entendre des slogans politiques mais se
gardent dépasser le cadre de la loi
quoi devrait-il être permis chez nous
hors du cadre de la loi donc vladimir
poutine a beau rappeler que les
manifestations n'étaient pas autorisés
les soutiens alexeï navalni ont promis
de nouvelles actions et ce dès le
week-end prochain
une fois de plus la réaction des
autorités russes sera scruté de très
près par la communauté internationale